hey everyone welcome to Abby's kitchen
every week I power through five long
days of runs work emails errands and
chores and by the time Saturday rolls
around
I'm comatose on the couch in TV marathon
mode no big deal until the TV business
turns a dwell full-blown junkie snack
[ __ ] sound familiar well we're in this
together this is my snack confession
here are some like top tips to help you
stop those mindless munchies tip one
don't deprive yourself all days
didn't you get meal times or forgetting
to eat is a recipe for a junky snack
attack because when we feel deprived it
is so hard to stop eating even after
we're full so a verse three meals plus
snack and even a mindful treat like my
favorite dark chocolate almond biscotti
chip to choose a satisfying snack skip
the fried food look for a snack that has
that same crunch factor but with a
combination of fiber and protein like
whole almonds you need a st. shading
snack cuz all those empty calories are
gonna have you rushing back to the
fridge in the middle of the rose
ceremony you can't miss the rose
ceremony tip 3 get busy Oh get your mind
out of that gutter actually that would
work pretty well but I just mean you
want to keep your hands and your mouth
and your little body gets busy while
you're watching TV so you can comment on
a YouTube channel you can have some tea
you could do a little paint-by-numbers
anything that's gonna stop you from
turning that TV binge into an eating
[ __ ]
tip for Portia it out and savor paws off
that family size chip bake and put your
snack into a small bowl I also play a
game with myself where I only eat during
the TV commercials what I'm not
distracted and I'm less likely to
overeat that means that I can actually
pay attention
to every flavor and texture and smell of
food and mindfully enjoy each bite and
tip 5 if you're still reaching into that
chip after all of that then this tip is
your last resort go brush your teeth
you're gonna think twice about having a
snack after you brush your teeth
I'm making mint and cheese stuff
together Oh gross and go all out with
that floss and the mouthwash - I'm
talking full-blown dental hygienist
cleaning hair
trust me no one's gonna be rushing to
the refrigerator after that I'd love to
hear your snap confessions so upload
yours and share them using the hashtag
snap confessions for more great videos
be sure to subscribe to my channel thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen hey
everyone I'm a bistro from Ali's kitchen
back with round 2 on my nutrition
Mythbusters because trust me there is no
shortage of bogus misinformation out
there when it comes to eating well